[Music]
foreign
good to have you with us this evening
for the Press preview it's our first
look at tomorrow's front pages and
checking out the headlines with us
tonight Rachel canliff senior associate
editor of the new Statesman who's joined
by Harry Cole the political editor of
the sun they're going to be with us from
now until just before midnight so good
to see you both we'll chat in a moment
after we've had a look at some of those
front pages uh hunt for lost Titanic sub
is how the Metro reports on the search
for a missing tourist submersible which
was diving to view the famous wrecked
liner on the bed at the Atlantic a UK
billionaire is amongst those on board
let's show you the front of the mail
also pictures the Titanic the missing
sub and that missing businessman Hamish
Harding
the express describes the rescue effort
for the five people on board As a Race
Against Time
same story in fact and the main item on
the front of tomorrow's Telegraph
Harris paper The Sun Also makes it the
lead item Brit on last sub lost sub to
Titanic
the guardian leads with tonight's
Commons votes backing the report that
said Boris Johnson lied to Parliament
over party Gates
is the Ft leading with the growing
pressure on homeowners from rising
mortgage rates along with the pressure
also increasing on which he soon act to
do something about it
according to the eye the current High
mortgage rates will stay that way for at
least another two years
and just so that Boris Johnson isn't the
only format PM taking Flack at the
moment the star turns its attention back
on Liz truss who it once described as a
wet lettuce but she didn't find it funny
apparently
and don't forget you can scan that QR
code that you see on screen during the
program have a look at all the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
listen to us discussing them and doing
that with me tonight Rachel kanliff and
Harry Cole
um all the front pages are highlighting
this awful story which broke this
afternoon about the Lost submersible
with a number of people on board going
to have a look at the Titanic
um Rachel
it's right to say this is a Race Against
Time they've got about 96 hours worth of
oxygen on board and they've already been
missing for for quite some time
yes it's the kind of story that you you
know might imagine in a blockbuster
Thriller only it's it's real it's a
submarine off the coast of Canada they
do trips to look at the wreckage of the
Titanic the cost of one of these trips
is a quarter of a million dollars so
it's it's it's not just uh it's not just
the kind of thing that you might pop pop
on to do on your holiday
um but it is it was meant to be a an
eight hour submersive dive and one hour
and 45 minutes into that they lost
contact with the submarine it's it's now
been lost for more than 24 hours and so
you've got divers and and rescue vessels
that are desperately trying to locate
this vessel
um unfortunately it's really really deep
it's it's several miles deep into the
ocean the ocean floor at that particular
point is full of sort of deep trenches
and that's where the wreck of the
Titanic is there's virtually no light
down there because you're you're so deep
and so locating anything in those kind
of conditions is a real Challenge and
obviously as you say the clock is
ticking yeah front of the daily mail
um has that haunting picture of the
wreck of the Titanic and also a smaller
picture Harry of the submersible that's
gone to have a look at it
um and on board Hamish Harding who is a
very wealthy man but he's also an
adventurer and also rather hauntingly he
posted a social media message saying how
excited he was that a weather window had
opened up allowing this dive to take
place
yeah so I think it's actually down to
something to two hours now if you take
into account how long they have been
missing
um if you think how long it took to find
the wreck of the Titanic this is going
to be a uh incredibly hard Rescue
Mission
um and uh as Rachel said it it does feel
like something out of a sort of
Adventure adventurous film I mean this
is not um this is not a mission without
risk the reason it costs so much is it
is an incredibly hard part of the world
to reach as a you know as a tourist so
to speak as a rescue operation it's
going to be even tougher so
um a very Grim story and a Race Against
Time I don't think really does it
justice I think it's um it's looking
pretty pretty bleak yeah that's the
headline on the on the Daily Express
Race Against Time to rescue Titanic sub
I suppose the final thoughts on this uh
Rachel really is that um you know it's
on all the front pages this story
um and yet there's so much going on in
the world but I guess it's a a sort of
an example of a story that is so unusual
that it merits big headlines
yeah it's unusual for a number of
reasons one is the sort of risk involved
one is the fact that it's the Titanic
which is something that everyone's heard
of and that kind of holds a particular
place in our cultural narratives and
cultural imagine Nation but I remember
when the school boys in Thailand were
trapped in in a cave and the world was
trying to work out how they were going
to rescue them that was also on the
front pages virtually every day for
several days in a row so I think there
is something about these
big rescue missions that does capture
something and warrant this kind of
attention and that's before you take
into account that there is a British man
on board which obviously gives it a
specifically UK angle for the the
interest as well yeah I was in Chile for
the to run up to the uh the miners being
rescued and that's all anyone was
talking about wasn't it for days on end
okay let's turn our attention then to
events uh back here Harry the front of
the Guardian tore his round on Johnson
as MPS vote to prove party gate report
there was some question about whether it
would be nodded through or whether a
vote would take place a vote did happen
354 MPS voting to endorse the report
seven voting against it there were cries
of uh who are you weren't there in the
in the house
indeed in fact one of the seven that
votes against it was Labor's Labor's
Chief whip because in order to force a
vote um someone has to shout a pose
before to test the will of the house
they call it before a division takes
place and Boris Johnson had made it very
clear to his supporters call off the
dogs he said don't die in a ditch don't
do this on my behalf you know there's a
foregone conclusion to this vote it's
going to go through with a whopping
majority not least because a couple of
hundred toys that appears have abstained
including the Prime Minister and most of
the cabinet
um so actually uh seven Tories uh sorry
seven seven people seven MPS voted
against the privilege of committee uh
report which obviously as we've been
talking about for what feels like many
many days now
um was throwing the book at Boris
Johnson if he'd still been in mp he
would have been kicked out of the
commons for 45 uh for 90 days he's in a
slightly pathetic petty little gesture
at the end of it he's having his past
revoked so he can't come into the House
of Commons without a physical visitors
school which I don't imagine has quite
had the impact that perhaps they thought
it might have done when that was a
little punishment was drawn up but it
really does show you kind of how weirdly
in the end Toothless the the commons uh
actually could be because Johnson's
already gone they've got their
conclusion there was many many hours
today of of pretty pretty obvious
virtual signaling from lots of people
who wanted to queue up to put the boot
in but um the sort of the horse is
already bolted so to speak so
um a fairly pointless day in the House
of Commons that I suspect could have
been wrapped up in about 20 minutes well
pointless uh Rachel but also hugely
symbolic
I think symbolic yes I mean Harry is
right in that it was a labor MP who
forced the vote clearly because labor
wanted the numbers they didn't just want
it to be nodded through they wanted it
on record that 354 MPS voted to endorse
the report which is a majority of MPS in
the House of Commons uh
uh overall and includes quite a high
number of conservatives and the only six
seven if you include the the labor MP 7
voted against and they wanted I think
those MPS who were going to the side
with Boris Johnson to put it down and
have their names on record and hey like
I I
can see why you might want to have a
have a list and force MPS to put their
money where their mouth is and really go
are you going to walk through that
division Lobby and obviously some did
others didn't I don't think Nadine Doris
is actually on the list of uh MPS who
who voted with the with Boris Johnson I
think she abstained as indeed did a very
high number of of Tory MPS but I think
that's interesting given that she
claimed that she was going to resign and
then hasn't yet resigned so could
technically have have voted for that and
on the the revoking of Johnson's
parliamentary pass I mean Harry is
absolutely right in that it is Pretty
Petty
um it's also quite obvious reading the
the full report that that additional
punishment was intended kind of as a
signal in part because of Johnson's
behavior when he got the the draft of
the report going sort of ballistic last
Friday as we saw and and uh briefing out
all the details of it that was seen as
particularly disrespectful and holding
element in contempt that's why that
additional punishment was added and it
does mean that he's going to find it
quite difficult if he ever wants to uh
do some casual lobbying work on the side
not being allowed into Parliament to
chill out with his former colleagues
without a visitor pass I think that's
that's pretty symbolic too there are
many jobs Harry either where you can you
can keep a pass after you've been
effectively sacked I mean what would
happen if the sun if God forbid you ever
were made redundant and you started
turning up at work Waltzing around going
to the canteen chatting to people
pretty much I'm just uh pretend I've
still got a job no fingers crossed that
won't be happening anytime soon thank
you
um no look Parliament is it it is it's
not a it's not a normal workplace is it
though it's there's a unique sort of
tradition that former MPS are allowed to
um sort of come and go I think even
their spouses are allowed access to the
building as well there's often if you
know if you're a kind of senior
politician there is a sort of occasional
ceremonial role that you get invited
back for but it does it doesn't yeah it
does it is one of those slightly strange
quirks about the building that actually
if you start to pull at the threads of
it you don't really understand why
anyone's got it but people just always
have
um and obviously former MB Rachel was
right former MPS have gone into trouble
uh by having a few of those if they do
end up becoming lobbyists but um I don't
think uh I don't think Boris Johnson is
gonna be becoming a lobbyist when they
seem to be stuffing his mouth with 250
Grand uh a pop for one of his speeches
so as long as that lasts and uh and
various other columns and books and the
like so I don't think it would need to
be uh lobbying just yet
anyway maybe for a change of prime
minister uh Rachel uh the other main
story uh on many of the front pages is
uh the mortgage crisis the average
two-year fixed rates have breached six
percent
um front of the Ft I'm real pain for
many homeowners
yeah so six percent was the figure in
December that that kind of tipped it and
it sort of signified crisis point and uh
we're at that again now which is a
little bit terrifying for for homeowners
with mortgages
um myself included uh there are sort of
renewed calls and increasingly loud
calls in the government to sort of quote
unquote do something about it and to
help homeowners deal with this when they
see that their monthly payments shoot up
the problem is that the mortgage rate
increases are because of Bank of England
interest rate Rises which are what the
government a part of the government's
plan to to curb inflation the idea is
that if you have higher interest rates
then you'll have higher mortgage rates
you'll get less demand in the economy
and inflation will come down which is
obviously one of rishis United's key
priorities and is a is a
really sort of big economic challenge
that impacts just about every aspect of
of our economy so on the one hand you've
got the government saying yeah this is
really painful but we need it to happen
in order to get inflation down which is
really important and then on the other
hand you've got sort of lobbying for but
the government must must do something to
to help people if they do though they're
kind of undermining the the the plan to
to store inflation so there are no good
options here and it's going to get very
very tricky yeah Harry the front of the
telegraph
um talking about those comments by
Michael Gove saying that 25-year fixed
rate mortgages could potentially help
solve uh the crisis I mean it's much
less devastating in other countries
isn't it in in France you can get a
25-year mortgage at the moment for three
percent why why is it so bad here
but there are high interest rates to be
it'd be unfair to say there aren't High
interest rates around around the around
the West
um America are starting to become more
that looks like it's peaked but it is it
is it is worse here and the government
are in real trouble here because 1.4
million people it's estimated are going
to have to remortgage this year and it
turns out that mortgage holders are
pretty vocal and pretty active block of
the
um electorate that take things pretty
seriously and actually turn out to vote
and no government has ever won an
election without having the support the
majority of mortgage holders and at the
moment if you're looking at some of the
polling done of them now they're all
going Labor's way so a ticking Time Bomb
for mortgage holders are taking time
bomb to the government this one they'll
be Keen to try and blame this trust for
it but uh actually those rates that
keeps keep keep going up and um there's
actually Rachel says there's not a huge
amount that actually they can do because
um it Bank of England is independent
they can make as much noise as they want
about the bank you know urging the bank
of England to take people into account
but we've got to a stage very quickly
actually in a way that has been never
unheard of before that actually
politicians you know Frontline
politicians are openly saying there
should be a sort of bailout for mortgage
uh holders which you know sort of
post-covered where the government
stepped in on furlough and then they
stepped on Energy prices and then they
you know now there's calls for them to
step in on mortgage prices a where's
there's money going to come from and B
where does it stop when does you know
it's basically a a One-Stop shop to a
sort of universal basically I think is
the inevitable conclusion of this and
that's you know a lot of people didn't
sign up for that the other point I very
quickly make on this is that there's
been some right Smiles I think from
renters who are hearing lots of mortgage
payers say well you know more than a
quarter of my income's now going to go
my mortgage to say well yes anyone
that's right to rent in the last 10
years can tell you that's actually not
bad compared to some of some of the
statistics we've seen from the amount of
money that people in the rental market
have to pay so you're gonna if you're
gonna if you're gonna bail out the
mortgage Market prepare for a lot of
very angry renters okay
um Rachel I'm going to do a slightly
strange thing now and ask you to
describe a story that's in the sun uh
just because Harry had a long answer I
know it's fine it's fine just tell us
about this um uh this poll Rachel about
um the Eco Elites
well the sun had done a poll of Voters
and how they feel about Net Zero
specifically how they feel about uh
having to pay more for various things in
order to reach out on Net Zero targets
and I'm gonna pass on over to Harry to
quickly hopefully say what he thinks it
says because I think it says something
different but I think he should get in
there first
very quickly it turns out that people
are you know politicians are very out of
touch with the public on this 85 percent
of the public say that politicians MPS
that pass this legislation do not
understand the pain that people are
feeling and they do not want to be the
ones that have to carry the cow for this
they don't want to get rid of their boy
they don't want to get there they don't
want to be forced to have electric cars
and they want things to slow down and
cost of living to come first okay that
was very honorable Rachel thank you
we'll give you uh lots more chance to
speak